okay I'm ready so um I honestly wouldn't
change much in terms of work of the
infrastructure the way most of countries
are adamant what I would probably put
all my energy on is on trying to make
sure that what we commit to ultimately
happens i think that the major gap
resides and then the big distance there
is between what people say they're going
to do and what they are ultimately doing
so it's basically the values in action
and the lack of a sort of a network or
mutual accountability would make things
really happened so I think that most
leaders express their commitment to
doing something but then when it comes
down to execution we run short and
making it really happen and realistic so
I think there's two things that should
happen the first one is there should be
a level of trust of an invitation for
people to raise their hand when they're
see anyone else deviating from their
word or their original commitment and
the second one is for those years to
build operational implications on a
personal consequences when those things
are ultimately not happen so I think
it's a matter of the walk and of the
talk of the work rather than the talk so
I think the top is fine that I think
where we where we lose our consciousness
is when we execute when we say we're
going to and we don't do it